and welcome back to Hannity so last week
the country learned that dr. Sebastian
Gorka was no longer working for the
White House however dr. korkor still
vows to work as hard as he can to push
through the President's agenda and to
drain the DC swamp joining us now the
man himself author of the best-selling
book defeating jihad former deputy
assistant to the president dr. Sebastian
Gorka I was surprised and frankly a
little bit shocked at this happening you
you told me that you believe you can
help push the President's agenda better
from the outside tell us what happened
well look what everybody understands I
think especially your viewers in the Fox
followers is last year on November the
8th it really was an insurgency
it wasn't the establishment that won it
wasn't the GOP it was a New York mogul a
tycoon of real estate with his merry
band of scrappy insurgents that won the
election against all odds crushed 16
competitors defeated a woman who'd spent
seven hundred million dollars okay so
when the inauguration happens this small
band of merry men and a couple of mint
women enter the White House and it's a
hostile takeover Sean a classic hostile
takeover well explain most people
wouldn't understand this dr. Gorka I
mean woody yeah I mean I actually looked
at some of the remarks you're talking
about bureaucrats policymakers and we
see Congress Republicans that are weak
and pathetic spineless visionless and
frankly I don't even think they have an
identity anymore but you're saying that
he's actually battling people with in
the White House what do you what does
that mean to poor these bureaucrats you
mean Obama holdovers it's not just Obama
holdovers I I'm not going to fuel the
palace intrigue because you know I was
the brunt of that as well as everybody
else on the side of the the maggot reign
for for eight months but the fact is one
of your Fox colleagues summed it up very
well they were talking about my boss
Steve Bannon leaving and they said
whatever you think of Steve Bannon he
would not have been at home in a Clinton
White House absolutely we have people in
the White House who not only would have
been at a
in a Clinton White House they probably
would have been cabinet members that's
the reality with a small band of people
go against the swamp I decided after the
Afghan speech by the president the best
thing I can do to support his agenda is
to come out of government service and
use all the tools available to a private
citizen and I assured the President on
Saturday after I resigned that I am go
he asked me to support him and I said
I'm going to support you 100%
from the outside to short it's about the
long game I know you mean that and I
will say this that the I've never seen a
president have to deal with a leak a day
from within its own government or
conversations with presidents and prime
ministers leaked and if they don't stop
that leaking the unmasking the
surveillance and all the shenanigans
Espionage Act violations it's going to
be problematic for the entire country